An interesting random variable
associated with the Bernoulli
process is the time
of the kth success
or the time of the
kth arrival, depending
on what kind of context
we have in mind.
So the picture is as follows.
The process starts and we wait
until the first arrival occurs,
and the time that it occurs,
we call that time Y1.
Then we keep
observing the process,
and there's a time at which
a second arrival comes.
We call that time Y2.
The process continues, and
there is a certain time
that the third arrival comes.
We call that time Y3.
Now, the time that the
first arrival comes,
this is also what we called T1.
T1 is this length.
It's the time until
the first arrival.
Let us give a name to the
time it takes from the first
to the second arrival,
and we call that time T2,
which is the second
inter-arrival time.
And similarly, we
will call T3 the time
between the second
and the third arrival.
So we define in general Tk to
be the difference between two
consecutive arrival times.
And of course, the time
of the third arrival
is the sum of T1 plus T2
plus T3, the first three
inter-arrival times.
And more generally, Yk is
going to be the sum of these k
inter-arrival times.
So in order to study the random
variable Yk and its properties,
the way that we can
proceed is to understand
first the random variables Ti.
What kind of random
variables are they?
Well, we know that T1, the
time until the first arrival,
has a geometric distribution
with parameter p.
Now, at the time of
the first arrival,
the process starts fresh.
So after this
time, there will be
a sequence of independent
Bernoulli trials,
and T2 will be the number
of Bernoulli trials
it takes until an arrival.
So T2 will also be geometric
with the same parameter, p.
Furthermore, because the
process starts fresh,
whatever happens in the
future after this time
is independent from whatever
happened in the past,
and so the random variable T2
will be independent from T1.
And then by a
similar argument, T3
will be independent
from T1 and T2
and will also have the same
geometric distribution.
Based on these
properties, we can now
go ahead and calculate
properties of Yk.
Yk is the sum of
random variables.
The expected value
of Yk is the sum
of the expected
values of the Ts.
Each one of the Ts has
a geometric distribution
with parameter p,
and in particular
has a mean of 1 over p.
By adding those means, we
obtain that the mean of Yk
is k over p.
Similarly, the
variance of Yk will
be equal to the sum
of the variances
of the Tis, the reason being
that the Tis are independent,
and so to find the
variance of the sum,
it's enough to just
add the variances.
And we have a formula for
the variance of a geometric,
and using that formula
and multiplying it by k,
we obtain the variance of Yk.
Finally, we would like to
calculate the PMF of Yk.
So we would like to find
this probability here,
the probability that Yk takes
on a specific value equal to t.
Notice that in this
argument, we're
thinking of k as a
fixed, given number.
For example, we're interested in
the time of the fifth arrival.
This is a random variable that
can take different values,
t, and we want to
find the probabilities
of those different values, t.
So think of k as being fixed and
t as a parameter that varies,
and we want to carry
out this calculation
for all possible choices of t.
Now, what is this event here?
This is the event that the
kth arrival occurs at time t.
So this means that at time
t, we have an arrival.
But for this to be
the kth arrival,
we must have k minus 1
arrivals in the previous time
slots, of which there's
t minus 1 of them.
The probability that
Yk is equal to t
is the probability that
these two events happen, k
minus 1 arrivals in t minus
1 slots and one arrival
at slot number t.
So we are looking
at the probability
that these two events occur.
Now this event, k minus 1
arrivals in t minus 1 slots,
is an event that's
completely determined
by whatever happens in the
first t minus 1 time slots,
whereas the event of an
arrival at slot time t
refers to whatever happens
during slot time t.
Because of our assumptions on
the Bernoulli process, whatever
happens during these
t minus 1 time slots
is independent from what
happens in slot number t.
So the probability of
these two events happening,
because of independence,
will be the probability
of the first event happening,
k minus 1 arrivals in time
t minus 1, times the probability
of an arrival at time t.
Now, the first probability is
given by the binomial formula.
In t minus 1 time slots, we
want to have k minus 1 arrivals.
And the binomial
formula gives us
an exponent, p to this
power times 1 minus p
to the power that's the
difference of these two
numbers, which is t minus k.
And then finally, we
multiply with the probability
of an arrival at time
t, which is equal to p.
This p will cancel the
exponent of minus 1 up here
and leads us to this
formula for the probability
that the kth arrival
happens at time t.
Notice the range of
the random variable Yk.
The kth arrival cannot
happen before time k.
You need at least k time
slots to obtain k arrivals,
so this probability
will be positive
only starting at time
k and for future times.
So this random variable
Yk, in general,
will have a PMF of this form.
It's zero for ts smaller than k,
and then at time k, in general,
it's going to be
a positive entry.
And for future values
of t, it will also
have positive entries.
And this PMF extends
all the way to infinity
because it is possible
that the kth arrival takes
an arbitrarily
long time to occur.
If we consider different
values of k, of course
we will get a different PMF.
The PMF of Y3 is different
than the PMF of Y2.
And the PMF of Y3
will generally sit
to the right of the PMF of
Y2 because the third arrival
generally will take longer to
occur than the second arrival.